[Music]
you have the idea to have me participate
in a WWE event what would I do if I was
in a WWF well you know well you know
everybody only at the end of the show
comes our more shaking hands and we're
talking and you can't hear anything cuz
the bands playing and you know we're
going to credits and stuff well
Conan told me that he would love to be
on a Dobby w event and I you know and so
far that was a year and a half ago knows
last in the show and I haven't seen him
turn up yet I'm still wait just don't
know what to do I'm happy to do it but I
don't know what role I've come to the
ring with me
if the SummerSlam is coming back to LA
this this next summer it's gonna be in
the Staples Center so I would put put it
put American football helmet on yeah
some shoulder pads maybe be inside a car
covered in pillows I mean I don't I
yeah I don't want just a helmet I I'm 68
years old I can't go out there we wrap
you in bubble wrap you'll be fine I
swear I'll take care of you Conan
nothing funny if I came out in bubble
wrap
that I might think with just my hair
sticking out and then you guys just sort
of pushed me around for a while until
you hear a soft crying when is the next
match is a is it something called a
chair match yes it's a chair match it's
bad it's a basic it much where you can
use chairs to hit your opponent with
steel chairs yeah and I'll be taking on
the big show who's seven foot two four
hundred and 460 pounds so I'm on the big
show forever that guy's massive yes he's
pretty does he get to use a chair too or
just you yes so he has a chair he has a
chair too
okay the odds they're not my favorite I
was just gonna say can I bet on this you
could really with a steel chair
absolutely it hurts it hurts a lot
actually yeah on my game plan is gonna
have to be fear literally trying to run
run rings random entire mouth but
knowing me I'll just probably tire
myself out and fall down and then I'll
you just hit me with the chair so right
I I'm gonna have to be better if better
plan of attack than that but yeah we
thought and obviously got tributed
troops as well okay I was in the Norfolk
Naval Base there last weekend we did a
huge show for them a lot of meet greets
got to sit in the captain's chair of the
George HW Bush aircraft carrier that's
great though to do that for the troops